yeah it's dope to see all y'all back
together man uh
you know and especially uh with the
right production
with organized noise that's right
you know what i'm saying like um this is
what i know you guys have been hearing
all the fans harping at you for so long
to do this specific project
including my back together with
organized noise why was the timing right
in 2020
because of that fact right there it was
it was resounding overwhelming
you know uh insisted consistent and
people always
say they want the old thing back man
we've been take us back to the beginning
you know what i mean take us back to
where it all started
and then sometimes you know you know in
your travels you know you get so far
away from home man like you know um
you know you you forget to look back i'm
saying you feel me
sometimes people people forget how to go
back i mean like
other times people aren't even welcome
to come back
fortunately man like you know home is
always where the heart is man like you
know
and you know um to come back to organize
lawyers to have
the original you know first generation
dungeon family man the ones who
you know who who who built the pillars
man who built and built the foundation
man like
it's uh it's incomparable and i'm saying
like it didn't also
have big and dream like that's the
original well this it was four five six
seven eight nine that's the original
nine the magnificent nine man you know
right there
what i mean so it's crazy man what can i
say man we proud
and exciting for people to get what
we've got how long was
uh the crew how long like i guess when
did the conception of this album start
how long have you guys
been working on this project and i know
all of you guys are aware of how
important this is to
dungeon family fans outcast fans goody
mob fans fans are real hip hop
so i'm sure you guys took your time when
did y'all start first working on this
project
to be for real with you we did this
project in the last five months
okay so this was uh under quarantine
yeah this was under quantity
oh [ __ ] okay everybody everything on
this album is brand new
i mean i guess that makes sense you know
a lot of the content that i heard and
then obviously the name of the album
that would that make sense
yeah so that that doesn't let you know
we once this quarantine hit
we made a decision that we was going to
come together we got we got in a secret
location on the south side of atlanta
and once the beast started flowing the
first record we recorded it was
survival kit and then one survival kit
to the amulet the avalanche came
it was just like we just kept going we
kept going so here it is again man
november 13th 2020 new album survival
kit
this is a long time coming